[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
how are you
oh look
we're coming near the end of the
terrible corona period
i feel it i feel it thank you yes
i can see i always
i always say i know why you're happy but
i feel the actual happiness tonight i do
because
yeah i know because well uh
president biden made a speech last night
did you watch your speech he said uh by
may 1st
uh vaccines everybody and he says july
4th we look like we'll be back
hopefully to normalcy wow that's pretty
i mean yes i i mean uh
it's uh it's been a while and also looks
like the schools will begin reopening i
know that means a lot to a lot of people
teachers around the country are already
practicing crying in their car in the
morning so
and also they passed the big relief bill
stimulus checks
this guy needs it tomorrow you know
they're going out
like summer checks are going out it's
like reparations for being stuck with
your family that's what
i feel
all the republicans every single one of
them voted against it the house you know
and the senate all every one of them uh
and of course now that there's benefits
they're already taking credit for the
benefits that are coming
they're like that guy in the office who
forgets your birthday and then somebody
gives you a gift and he goes
that's from all of us
also this week we finally got some
clarity on the most pressing issue of
our time
did megan make kate cry or did kate make
megan cry
tell me now so i know who we're not
talking to at lunch
this i never understood this fixation
with the royal family but boy this week
you're all talking about it
you can't avoid it oprah did a big
interview with harry and megan
on cbs which makes sense because when i
turned it on
boy did i see bs
well
you can you can hate the racism but not
love them for everything else
you know i mean i mean megan did claim
that before dating harry she she never
googled him and she said she didn't know
much about the royal family
yeah in the first three days she thought
it was ed sheeran
that's how much she didn't come on
just don't lie to me you know come on
megan you filmed your television show
for years in toronto
every time you bought a moccaccino you
use coins with your mother-in-law's face
on it i think
but a question a big bombshell not that
it's not a big bombshell that there's
horrible racism it is terrible in the
royal family
and i'm sure it was very painful and uh
members of the royal art hierarchy she
said uh were actually
asking her you know when she was
pregnant how dark the baby's skin would
be
and the queen said it problematic she
said this is why we've always
discouraged sex outside the family
so who else is on
else is on the [ __ ] list this week uh oh
uh
biden's dog major
yeah a major fuck-up
he's back in delaware he's like melania
left
she spent the first six months in new
york it's a common thing now
but uh biden's dog bit somebody and the
secret service says this is the first
biting incident they can remember
although they did once have to pull
lindsey graham off trump's leg
that's um
no i i say it with love
but i'm so glad you're in a good mood
this is our coroniversary it was
almost exactly a year ago that we did
our last show here and you all remember
what happened then and
so we have a lot of interesting stats
now about what happened during the last
year
people's weight is up drinking more
mental health issues
and less sex a condition previously
known
as marriage that's you know i
kid oh i joke about that
also this i thought i thought that this
was interesting also men have developed
an inflated sense of how often step moms
have sex with their stepsons
i think pornhub fans know what that
means
but it is amazing when you think about
it in just 12 months covet went around
the world touching everyone
like andrew cuomo uh oh he's um
he just he's in big trouble he's in big
trouble last week
he's one of those stories every week the
numbers go up now it's a
six woman and it's starting to look like
the only way
we're going to be able to stop him is
herd immunity
[Applause]
the latest is that apparently he called
an aide to help this is his way of
you know making out with the ladies
called an aide to help come into his
office
privately to help with his cell phone
this is the second accuser who says that
that was you know help with my cell
phone was the ruse
because nothing makes women hotter than
an older guy who can't figure out his
phone stop it governor
oh governor stop it i
i'm so wet you're gonna have to put me
in rice
you